ça y est c'est officiel les nouveaux
Samsung Galaxy S24 sont arrivés on a
donc trois modèles cette année également
S24 S24 plus et S24 ultra le gros focus
cette année c'est l'intelligence
artificielle vous allez voir il y a deux
processeurs différents il y a énormément
de nouvelles fonctionnalités basées sur
l'IA vous êtes prêts allez c'est parti
je vous en premier élément qui est
intéressant ici c'est le design toujours
un peu dans la même idée toujours dans
le même esprit que des écrans plats
aucun écran incurvé sur aucun modèle la
particularité c'est qu'on va avoir des
bords qui vont être un peu plus fins par
rapport à ce qu'on avait sur la
génération précédente des tranches qui
vont être ég éement un peu plus plate
sur les galaxies S24 et S24 plus on va
retrouver au niveau du dos un Corning
Gorilla glace victus 2 mais également à
l'avant sur leultra c'est différent on
va avoir au dos bien évidemment toujours
un corningor glace victus 2 donc
extrêmement résistant par contre à
l'avant et bien là on va se retrouver
avec un corningor glace Armor l'Armor il
a la particularité d'être quatre fois
plus résistant et surtout de venir
réduire les reflets de 75 % ce qui fait
que vous êtes vraiment pas embêté là il
y a énormément de lumière tous les côtés
je regarde je vois quelques petits
reflets si vraiment je viens pousser
mais à savoir qu'ici il y a des
éclairages de studio donc c'est
relativement normal mais ça vous évitera
si vous êtes en plein soleil vous avez
des éclairages un peu de tous les côtés
et bien vraiment de venir souffrir au
niveau de vos yeux surtout la
particularité que j'ai venu retrouver
sur le ultra et ça c'est vachement bien
on l'a vu chez Apple cette année et là
on le retrouve ici c'est-à-dire que vous
allez avoir un cadre en titane alors que
sur autres modèles vous avez un cadre en
aluminium le titane sera 56 % plus
résistant que l'aluminium ce qui confère
au Samsung Galaxy S24 ultra d'être
extrêmement résistant et en plus de ça
il y a plein de couleurs différentes
alors la couleur que vous avez là voyez
c'est écrit ici c'est le titanium yellow
vous les avez également en violet en
couleur argent bref ici il y a
énormément de couleurs différentes je
vous les montre pas toutes je vous
invite à venir les découvrir directement
sur le site samsung.com je vous met bien
évidemment un lien juste en bas dans la
description c'est vrai que c'est Samsung
Galaxy S24 coûte quand même relativement
cher des fois on peut se poser la
question peux venir les acheter c'est
vrai mais je vais venir débloquer
beaucoup d'argent il y a une autre
solution qui est intéressante et c'est
un vrai bon plan que je voulais partager
avec vous pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
pourriez pas les louer avec beaucoup
d'avantages derrière je vous explique
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée avec mon partenaire next mobile
c'est une entreprise française vous
allez pouvoir venir louer votre Samsung
Galaxy S24 à 42,99 9 et votre Samsung
Galaxy S24 ultra à
64,99 € par mois et le côté extrêmement
positif c'est que c'est sans engagement
et en plus de ça c'est sans hausse de
mensualité ni frais cachés autre
avantage et non des moindres qui qui est
vraiment un super bon plan chez NeXT
mobile c'est que tous les 12 mois vous
changeer pour le modèle supérieur ça
veut dire que si là vous prenez le S24
ou le S24 ultra et bien l'année
prochaine au bout de 12 mois et bien à
la même période vous pourrez aller sur
le S25 et le S25 ultra autre élément qui
est super important et auquel on pense
pas nécessairement c'est que si vous
faites tomber votre smartphone et que
vous venez casser l'écran et bien il
faut savoir que la réparation d'un écran
sur smartphone ça peut aller jusqu'à 600
€. et bien avec next mobile il vous
donne en plus une assurance casse et vol
incluse qui vous permet d'avoir une
totale tranquillité d'esprit il y a
aussi une chose qui me plaît beaucoup
chez NeXT Mobil c'est qu'ils ont un
modèle échoresonsable à savoir que les
smartphones qu'ils vous ont loué bien
lorsqu'ils reviennent chez eux ils vont
les faire reconditionner en France et en
circuit court pour pouvoir ensuite les
remettre sur le marché et clou du
spectacle je vous donne accès un code
promo de 30 € qui vous permet de venir
tester les services de NX mobile sur
l'ensemble de leur site le code c'est
mgux 30 si vous voulez un Galaxy S24 ou
un S24 ultra et que vous ne voulez pas
venir l'acheter pensez réellement à
louer à un tarif maîtrisé je vous mets
bien évidemment un lien dans la
description pour aller venir découvrir
et tester les services de Next mobile on
comprend un peu le design maintenant je
veux qu'on rentre un peu plus en
profondeur au niveau de l'écran parce
que je vous parle dans quelques instants
de l'a et vous allez voir ce qu' propose
en nia est absolument incroyable on en
parle un peu plus loin dans la vidéo les
chapitré si vous voulez y aller vous
pouvez cliquer dessus alleer voir mais
croyez-moi ce qu'on regarde au niveau
des écrans et intéressant parce qu'on
pass beaucoup de temps sur nos écrans à
venir regarder nos smartphones que ce
soit pour et bien naviguer tout
simplement que ce soit pour le le gaming
des films des séries ils sont venus
augmenter très légèrement très très très
légèrement les tailles d'écran un poil
des résolutions mais pas partout vous
allez voir c'est aussi un sujet qui est
vraiment passionnant vous avez des
dalles LTP partout ça c'est déjà le truc
à venir retenir là c'est le Galaxy S24
sur le S24 vous avez un écran de 6,2
pouces je crois que c'est 0,1 pouces
plus grand que ce qu'on avait avant et
surtout la résolution c'est du Full HD
plus écran bien évidemment comme je vous
le dis ltpo qui valait de 1 Hz jusqu'à
120 Hz et surtout une dalle dynamique
AMOLED 2x qui est juste absolument bien
calibré le S24 plus lui a forcément un
écran un peu plus grand c'est une
diagonale de 6,7 pouces et la
particularité qu'il a et qui est
vraiment vraiment cool et bien c'est que
là vous avez une résolution quad HD plus
3120 par 1040 1040 1060 pixel 1440 j'ai
mes notes je connais pas tout par cœur D
ltpo également et en plus ce qui est
intéressant avec une techno ltpo c'est
que ça vient jouer sur l'autonomie
réellement et bien évidemment ici c'est
une dalle dynamicque AMOLED 2x le ultra
c'est encore tout autre chose on monte
carrément ici à 6,8 pouces alors vous me
direz que d'un côté entre le plus et le
ultra 6,7 6,8 il y a pas non plus un
monde le truc est vraiment intéressant
ici voyez c'est que c'est un écran plat
tout plat ça ça change de la génération
précédente ils sont venus également
travailler au niveau des bords pour
qu'on les débord plus fins et que les
écrans aillent plus loin et réduire
légèrement la taille du châssis c'est
très très bien réussi on se parle
également i d'une résolution quad HD+
dynamic amolet 2x ltpo 110 on connait
l'histoire c'est très classique et là où
ça vient fou complètement fou c'est à
l'extérieur on a des écrans qui montent
jusqu'à 2600 Nitz c'est 40 % de
luminosité en plus croyez-moi là je suis
blouis vous allez voir vous allez tout
voir derrière c'est incroyable là vous
avez le Galaxy S24 ultra là vous avez le
S23 ultra ça va vous sauter aux yeux on
voit vraiment bien en pleine lumière je
vous assure que ça cartonne la gueule
avec le S24 ultra ici par rapport au S23
le risque que vous avez ici c'est de
voir votre niveau de batterie diminue
très rapidement en venant pousser la
luminosité au max là on arrive sur la
partie qui m'intéresse réellement et
dont je vous ai déjà parl il y a
quelques mois alors souvenez-vous il y a
quelques mois en arrière je vous emmene
avec moi à Hawi découvrir le nouveau
processeur le plus haut de gamme de
Qualcom le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 et je vous
disais qu'il y avait de l à embarquer
que c'était absolument incroyable c'est
notamment ici ce qu'on va retrouver ici
mais Samsung nous a surpris l'année
dernière dans tous les smartphones de la
gamme Galaxy S S23 S23 plus S23 ultra
ils avaient mis le Snapdragon 8 gen 2
les générations précédentes sur les
Galaxy S21 on avait de lexinos sur le
marché européen et aux US Canada on
retrouvait des processeurs de Qualcom et
bien cette année ils sont dit on va
mettre un peu des deux comme ça on coupe
la porir en deux à savoir que sur le
Galaxy S24 S24 plus vous retrouvez le
processeur maison de Samsung c'est
l'xyos 2400 gravé en 4 nanom tandis que
sur le modèle ultra vous avez le snap
dragon 88 Gen 3 je donne un peu de spec
très rapidement comme ça vous serez
vraiment au point sur le S24 vous avez 8
Go de RAM et 628 soit 256 Go de stockage
la technram c'est de l'alpd 5x très très
bien sur le modèle plus vous avez 12 Go
de RAM et vous avez soit 256 soit 512 Go
de stockage tandis que sur les Ultra
forcément c'est la machine qui va
défoncer le plus vous avez 12 Go de RAM
256 512 ou carrément 1 t de stockage qui
dit processeur performant dit forcément
gaming et c'est ce qu'on vient
rechercher également avec ce smartphone
je vous l'ai dit il y a plein d'usages
différents on les connaît tous le gaming
les séries les photos les vidéos les
souvenirs bref et il a dans quelques
instants je vous y emmène et bien ici
ils sont venus travailler sur leur
chambre à vapeur pour permettre de venir
refroidir votre smartphone lors des
grandes parties de gaming alors là ils
nous ont montré un petit peu un
échantillon des différentes chambres à
vapeur pour se rendre compte réellement
qu'ils sont venus réellement les faire
un peu plus grandes et permett de mieux
dissiper la chaleur là vous avez par
exemple la chambre à vapeur du S23
versus le S24 on voit quand même il y a
une évolution assez significative là sur
le côté vous avez le S23 ultra versus le
S24 ultra une fois de plus vous voyez la
taille de la chambre à vapeur ça fait
vraiment pas marer ils sont vraiment
venus améliorer cette partie là et de
l'autre côté là vous arrivez sur le S23
plus S24 plus avec vous le voyez une
fois de plus une chambre à vapeur qui va
être plus grande en moyenne elles sont
1,9 fois plus grande ce qui nous permet
ici d'avoir une meilleure dissipation
thermique et lorsque vous allez jouer à
des jeux et bien vous aurez pas le
smartphone qui chauffe au dos vous
allezêt tranquille un des gros sujets
qui nous apporte ici c'est la question
de l'autonomie parce que bien évidemment
l'autonomie d'un smartphone c'est pas la
taille de la batterie uniquement c'est
la taille de la batterie ça va être
également votre technologie de RAM de r
ça va être bien évidemment votre
processeur derrière soit il est
énergivore soit il l''est pas et bien là
on va regarder pour l'instant la taille
de la batterie on parlera consommation
d'énergie un peu plus tard dans une
prochaine vidéo à savoir que sur le S24
vous avez une batterie de 4000 m qui
nous permet d'avoir 4 He d'autonomie en
plus en tout cas c'est ce que vient
annoncer aujourd'hui Samsung 4 He
d'autonomie c'est dû également grâce au
processeur et à tout ce que je vous
décrivais juste avant avec de la
recharge 25 W sans fil 10 W sur le
modèle plus vous avez une batterie de
4900 mahh de la recharge 45 W à partir
du modèle plus jusqu'au ultra de la
recharge sans fil également 10 W et on a
ici plus 4,5 he d'autonomie ce qui est
un très joli gain par rapport à la
génération précédente tandis que sur le
modèle ultra on a une batterie de 5000
mahh très très grosse avec toujours de
la recharge 45 W filire 10 W sans fil et
là il nous annonce une autonomie un gain
d'autonomie de 3,5 he donc on voit que
ces modèlesl les modèles de 2024 de
Samsung dans la gamme Galaxy S vont
aller plus loin entre 3h et 4h
d'autonomie gagnée le slogan de Samsung
cette année c'est Galaxy Ia is here
l'intelligence artificielle dans les
Samsung Galaxy sont enfin arrivés vous
allez voir il y a un très gros condensé
d'intelligence artificielle tout ce
qu'on a vu arriver avec l générative au
travers de chat GPT et compagnie bref
tout ça se retrouve à l'intérieur de
votre smartphone c'est passionnant parce
que vous allez pouvoir le faire ce
qu'ils appelleent le offline donc c'est
le smartphone directement en mode avion
vous allez avoir plein d' à l'intérieur
il y a quatre gros focus que nous montre
ici Samsung au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle le premier c'est le fait de
communiquer le deuxième c'est le fait de
s'informer le troisème c'est travailler
le 4e c'est créer alors on va regarder
le fait de communiquer je vous explique
par exemple vous êtes à l'étranger comme
nous ici aux États-Unis à côté de San
Francisco et vous voulez parler à
quelqu'un sauf que vous vous ne parlez
absolument pas anglais et bien c'est pas
grave vous prenez votre Samsung Galaxy
S24 n'importe lequel de la gamme et il
va venir vous permettre de communiquer
avec quelqu'un qui a une langue
étrangère extrêmement facilement que ce
soit au téléphone que ce soit par
message ou que ce soit comme ça
directement en face à face il y a 13
langues en tout en fait ce que vous
allez faire dans votre Smartphone vous
allez télécharger un pack de langues qui
va faire entre 300 à 500 m comme ça vous
allez pouvoir venir parler avec
n'importe qui offline ici le cas d'usage
qu'on va avoir c'est soit un restaurant
soit un taxi on va appeler un restaurant
en Espagne donc là j'appelle col assist
live et je choisis français espagnol
bonjour je voudrais réserver un
restaurant pour 5 personnes samedi soir
à 19h s'il vous plaît donc là c'est en
train de traduire la personne en face va
venir me demander peutêtre confirmation
s'il y a besoin ou une information plus
mon nom pour la réservation que saisje
encore oui pour 5 personnes pour samedi
soir à
[Musique]
19h et vous voyez tous ces va viens qui
se font directement jusqu'au fait
d'arriver à la fin de l'app téléphonique
ù vous raccrocher donc c'est une
fonctionnalité qui est très simple très
maline et qui vous permet de venir
converser un peu partout dans le monde
il y a également une autre fonction qui
est intéressante si par exemple vous
arrivez devant quelqu'un et que vous
voulez que votre smartphone Vienne
traduire ce que la personne vous dit
directement et bien vous avez une
fonctionnalité ici qui s'appelle
interprète vous venez ici dans votre
menu et vous allez chercher ici la
fonction interpréteur rassurez-vous ça
sera en français vous choisissez votre
langue ici on va se dire la langue
française je vais venir lui poser une
question pour venir par exemple faire
une réservation pour le restaurant donc
là j'appuie je voudrais réserver
une table pour 5 personnes au restaurant
pour samedi soir à 19h merci donc là
j'appuie il a reconnu mon texte et là il
vient le traduire directement en
anglais ça ne s'arrête pas là parce que
vous avez également d'autres
fonctionnalités d' qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver notamment grâce au clavier
Samsung alors je vous montre regardez
lorsque vous venez créer une
conversation on va venir chercher à
parler à qui là par exemple à Google
juste là on va lui envoyer un petit
message et là vous allez voir que on va
lui marquer par exemple bonjour Comment
vas-tu mon lapin vous allez sur le petit
bouton juste en bas là qui va servir
pour les vous choisissez vous allez
avoir une traduction directement du chat
il vous donnera un style qui est
intéressant alors vous verrez vous
l'urez en français on testera ça plus
tard mais le style d'écriture et après
on va pouvoir travaillir sa grammaèire
directement ici alors là hop là
automatiquement il va reconnaître mon
texte et on va aller vers l'anglais donc
là on envoie on va écrire à Google btim
mon lapin et il lui met good morning how
are you my rabbit donc ça permet de
venir écrire très très facilement
quelqu'un et à chaque fois qu'on va
envoyer un message ça envoa votre texte
dans votre langue de base mais également
la traduction en dessous dans la langue
de votre choix donc c'est extrêmement
simple pour venir converser avec des
amis qui ne parlent pas votre langue
alors là je vous montre ça il y en a
également une autre c'est le witing
steel je vais venir taper un petit texte
je vais super bien au top là je vais sur
mon Ia je vais sur le writing style
directement là style voyez l'accent qui
est top donc là il est en train de venir
rechercher et là il vous propose en fait
des choses soit plutôt professionnel
tout va très bien merci plutôt cojuol je
vais trop bien en ce moment je suis un
peu super cool tout va bien social je
vous vais super bien au top hashtag
positif hashtagheureux hashtagve vous
avez un côté très poli je vais très bien
merci emojify je vais bien au top donc
vous voyez ça vous aidera pour venir
choisir le style il est adapté surtout à
l'interlocuteur que vous avez en face de
vous ces fonctionnalités qu'on retrouve
sur le clavier Samsung ou les retrouvera
également sur d'autres smartphones de
Samsung très bientôt vu que c'est lié au
clavier Samsung sur le zflip 5 et
compagnie bref ça va venir s'intégrer
dans d'autres produit donc ça c'est
quand même vachement bien je vous parlez
d'A bien évidemment pour venir
communiquer maintenant on va venir
parler d'A pour venir s'informer ce
smartphone est le premier intégrer une
toute nouvelle fonctionnalité qui a été
c-éveloppée avec Google qui s'appelle
entourer pour chercher en fait c'est la
je pense la seule fonctionnalité ici di
qui vous demandera d'être connectter
internet pour venir chercher des
résultats vous allez voir c'est très
très simple en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que vous allez venir vous aller
naviguer sur le web et vous voyez à un
moment une image qui vous intéresse
quelquel soit dit tien c'est quoi ce
truc au lieu d'essayer de taper les mots
clés tiens je cherche une espèce de
lampe ou un truc comme ça j'ai vu GN et
vous retrouvez pas vous galéz et bien là
vous venez avec votre douir vous
entourer et ça va venir vous le proposer
directement dans des résultats de
recherche signé Google c'est extrêmement
malin regardez ça on est sur un site
français très connu vous connaissez le
Journal du Geek on va essayer de trouver
un truc un peu marrant tiens par exemple
là cette image là donc là c'est Prince
of Persia hop là on va virer l'annonce
mais imaginons que je sache pas ce que
c'est si ça ça m'intéresse et bien je
vais venir faire un appuil long sur mon
bouton en bas ça va me faire comme une
capture d'écran et là je viens entourer
ce que je vais rechercher je veux
rechercher ce bonhomme là pour savoir ce
que c'est donc là j' mes résultats de
recherche et là il vous le met Prince of
Persia et là je vais retrouver plein
d'articles plein d'infos directement sur
cette image que je vais avoir à droite à
gauche tiens là typiquement je vois que
je vais avoir des consoles je descends
directement ces images là ah tiens ça
m'intéresse je laisse appuyer
directement et je viens entourer la
console du centre qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce truc là donc là il va venir
rechercher directement et là j' des
résultats pour cette console que je vais
retrouver directement soit pour venir
l'acheter soit avoir des infos bref des
vidéos directement dessus bref tout ce
qui correspond au produits que je suis
venu entourer et bien je le retrouve ici
et c'est extrêmement simple et surtout
très très très intuitif aujourd'hui
c'est une exclu sur les Samsung Galaxy
S24 mais qu'on retrouvera plus tard sur
d'autre smartphone bien évidemment parce
que c'est une fonctionnalité Google que
vous recherchiez un objet un lieu un
texte un tableau vous allez pouvoir le
faire directement avec entouré pour
chercher je trouve ça extrêmement malin
parce que c'est une nouvelle façon de
venir faire des recherches directement t
son smartphone toujours dans la partie
s'informer vous avez un assistant web
qui vous permettra de venir résumer des
articles de venir les copier vous allez
pouvoir les mettre ailleurs si vous
voulez en gros vous synthétisez de
l'information de venir les traduire
directement bref de faire plein de
choses directement depuis le navigateur
Samsung par exemple je suis sur un un
test de Prince of Persia alors j'ai pas
envie de me faire tout le test trouve ça
un peu relou de me le faire en entier
hop là pas autant relou que la pub et
bien ensuite je viens cliquer sur ces
trois petites étoiles juste en bas et là
il va venir me proposer summarize ou
translate alors que c'est la version
anglaise mais vous l'aurez en français
soyez tranquille on va aller sur
summarize par exemple donc il va me
faire un petit résumé directement de
tout ce que j'ai dans cet article là
Prince of person g un retour au force
réussie donc c'est un jeu 2D il propose
un mélange de tradition et de modernité
donc là voyez j'ai un vrai résumé de
l'article et si je veux le partager avec
un pote à moi qui par exemple parle
anglais mais ne parle pas français et
bien voyez j'ai du French English et là
il me traduit directement ça là je vais
directement sur la newsroom de Samsung
par exemple on va se trouver un article
quel qu'il soit hop là par exemple
celui-là pareil de la même manière mes
petites étoiles summarize donc là il est
en train de pédaler pour venir me
résumer l'article que je vais avoir ici
ensuite je vais mettre translate donc là
je me mets de l'anglais alors pas en
espagnol mais plutôt en français ça
serait un peu mieux pour moi et comme ça
je vais venir récupérer directement un
résumé cet article qui était pour en
anglais vous pouvez le faire avec des
articles en coréen si vous voulez c'est
quand même vachement pratique donc si
vous voulez par exemple lire un article
dans une langue que vous ne comprenez
absolument pas une revue médicale ou
compagnie et qui vous paraît par exemple
extrêmement pertinent qui est très très
très long et bien résumé traduction vous
avez l'essentiel de l'information et ça
il faut reconnaître quand même que vous
l'avez dans votre poche et c'est
vraiment génial alors on a regardé
communiquer on a regardé s'informer mais
on a pas regardé travailler parce que
oui bien évidemment avec ces Samsung
Galaxy S24 on peut venir travailler avec
des outils qui sont franchement disons
le très efficace c'est dans
l'application voice recorder qu'on va
voir en anglais ici c'est en fait pour
venir enregistrer votre voix
l'enregistreur je pense c'est le nom en
français bref donc ce que vous allez
faire c'est que vous allez dans votre
enregistreur vous allez enregistrer par
exemple une petite présentation comme je
pourrais la faire là pour présenter les
smartphones et vous allez voir ce que
lia vous permet de faire je vais don mon
application directement là et là je vais
enregistrer je vous parle aujourd'hui du
nouveau Samsung Galaxy S24 qui est un
très joli téléphone vous en avez
également d'autres modèles vous avez le
Galaxy S24 plus vous avez également le
Galaxy S24 ultra le ultra et tant titane
au niveau du châssis qui est absolument
incroyable et surtout ils font très
jolies promesses au niveau de la photo
mais ça je vous le montre dans quelques
instants voilà donc pour ces smartphone
qui vont sortir très bientôt et une fois
de plus allez voir le lien en bas dans
la description donc là c'est ma note
vocale je vais l'appeler Greux et je
l'enregistre là je vais la retrouver
juste ici ma note vocale vous voyez et
là il me propose de venir la transcrire
donc d'avoir le texte directement je
choisis la langue je veux la transcrire
en français et là il est en train de
pédaler pour venir transcrire
directement ce que j'ai enregistré il y
a quelques instants donc l' transcrit
vous le marque voyez je vous parle
aujourd'hui du nouveau Samsung Galaxy
s204 bon j'ai du mal articulé qui est
très joli téléphone g et vous avez tout
votre texte et ça si vous vous dites B
ok ça c'est bien mais j'ai pas envie de
m'embêter et bien je vais sur summary
donc résumé donc là il vous fait un
résumé et il vous le dit présentation du
Samsung Galaxy s204 une fois de plus
c'est un peu planté là-dessus nouveau
téléphone avec un design élégant et des
fonctionnalités il est disponible dans
plusieurs modèles don le S24 plus et le
s204 ultra ultra et ten Titan j'ai du
mal articuler parce que normalement
c'est plutôt pas mal le châssis est est
incroyable et les promesses au niveau de
la photo sont aléchantes donc vous voyez
c'est assez Dingo alors on se le teste
dans quelques jours là c'est qu'une
découverte et on va voir si
effectivement et bien c'est moi qui qui
a parlé un peu trop vite ou s'il a un
peu de mal mais on regarde ça d'ici
quelques jours comme sur le Galaxy S24
ultra on a le S Pen le sen vous le
connaissez c'est le stylet qui est juste
là qui vous permet de venir travailler
directement prendre des notes dessiner
griffonner faire des croquis bref faire
beaucoup de choses et bien vous allez
avoir des fonctionnalités vraiment
intéressantes qu'on connaissait déjà
vous prenez des notes et ensuite ça le
transforme mon texte ça on connaissait
ça existait déjà mais les
fonctionnalités d'IA que vous avez à
l'intérieur et bien vous les retrouverez
également ici à savoir que vous allez
pouvoir venir résumer directement des
notes que vous avez pris par exemple
vous allez pouvoir également ensuite les
traduire bref toutes l'a que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure avec de l'audio
une fois que vous avez un texte qui est
généré et bien dès lors que vos notes
sont générées en texte vous aurez les
mêmes fonctionnalités mais on peut venir
également créer avec ces smartphones
créer bien évidemment de la photo créer
de la vidéo je sais pas si vous êtes
d'ailleurs créateur ou créatrice de
contenu vous allez voir que ces
smartphones sont très polyvalent il y a
eu pas mal de petites modifications qui
ont été fait au niveau des capteurs
photo notamment au niveau du S24 ultra
par rapport au S23 ultra l'année
dernière mais globalement la recette qui
sont venu appliquer ici avec de l'a est
vraiment intéressante sur les S24 et S24
plus vous allez avoir la même
configuration au niveau de la photo
c'està-dire un capteur principal de 50
mégapixel qui ouvre F 1.8 avec ce qu'ils
appelleront un zoom x 2 qualité optique
on va venir en fait venir croper dans
votre capteur pour vous sortir 1 x 2
mais sans perdre de qualité vous allez
également avoir un ultra grand angle de
12 m pixel et un téléobjectif de 10
mégapixel avec un zoom optique x 3 qui
va aller jusqu'à un zoom x 30 la
nouveauté elle va se faire au niveau du
Samsung Galaxy S 24 ultra avec ses cinq
capteurs on se dirait que c'est un peu
comme le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra mais
en réalité pas du tout pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont n travailler une recette
légèrement différente pour lia déjà vous
avez un gros capteur principal un grand
angle qui est un 200 mégapixel vous
allez également avoir un ultra grand
angle de 12 mégapixel un premier
téléobjectif de 10 mégapixel avec un
zoom optique x 3 et un deuxième
téléobjectif cette fois-ci de 50
mégapixel mais avec un zoom optique qui
valait jusqu'à x 5 optique x 5 et non
pas x 10 l'année dernière on avait un
deuxième téléobjectif de 10 mgapixel
avec un zoom optique x 10 et là il y a
un plus grand capteur et on va un peu
moins loin mais en fait ce que nous dit
Samsung c'est que bien que vous ayez pas
un zoom optique x 10 mais un X 5 du fait
que vous ayez un plus grand capteur mais
bien évidemment plus avec le processeur
que vous avez à l'intérieur et toute lia
embarqué et bien en réalité vous aurez
de bien meilleures photos ce qui nous
dit c'est que vous allez avoir une
qualité optique x 2 x 3 x 5 x 10 même en
X 10 vous seriez a priori bien mieux en
terme de qualité que ce que vous aviez
l'allé dernière avec le Samsung Galaxy
S23 ultra bien évidemment on regardera
le résultat dans quelques jours mais sur
le papier je trouve ça en tout cas très
alléchant on peut aussi venir filmer en
8k à 30 images par seconde et bien
évidemment en 4K 60 et il y a de super
slow motion en 4K à 120 également le
point qui est super super super super
intéressant c'est tout ce que vous
permet de faire l'IA ici et bien
évidemment les processeurs déjà votre Ia
elle va venir retoucher vos images elle
va venir analyser plan par plan image
par image pour maximiser le résultat et
ça pas uniquement lorsque vous allez
venir zoomer sur un Space zoom x 100 ou
en venant zoomer sur un x 50 non ça il
va le faire même sur un X 10 sur un X 5
ce qui permettra que toutes les images
que vous allez prendre vont être
totalement optimisé grâce au deep
learning et grâce à l'algorithme que
nous propose ici Samsung au niveau des
fonctionnalités d'IA lorsque vous avez
fait des photos bien vous venez hop là
lever vers le haut là je peux mettre un
flou au niveau de de mon background je
peux venir supprimer des reflets je peux
venir remastteriser la photo ça permet
de venir modifier directement mes photos
de venir les améliorer alors si je le
souhaite ou pas mais là voyez
typiquement vous avez un reflet donc là
je viens comme ça il va venir travailler
hop là on en supprime le reflet donc là
il est en train de pédaler il va venir
me supprimer le reflet ce qui fait que
ça me maximise totalement mes photos et
puis il y a un autre truc qui est
intéressant c'est par exemple vous avez
fait une photo que vous êtes légèrement
de travers et bien vous pouvez venir
vous recadrer directement et lia vous
permettra de venir créer du contenu va
venir générer du contenu par rapport à
votre image de base ça c'est grâce à l
générati le truc qui peut être
potentiellement un peu relou c'est que
vous allez avoir en watermark vous
indiquera que l'image a été retouchée
grâce à de l'intelligence artificielle
là par exemple regardez j'appuie sur ces
quelques petits boutons là et là je vais
pouvoir venir modifier mon image grâce à
da hop là je peux venir modifier et là
il me manque plein de contenu donc là je
met générer lui il va venir me générer
directement du contenu avec de
l'intelligence artificielle pour venir
compléter la partie manquante et là vous
voyez il est venu me créer autre chose
alors bon j'avais mon espèce de
watermark un peu dégueu en bas et
c'était pas terrible mais par contre
tout le reste est vraiment très très
très très bien fait et je trouve ça
extrêmement ble ils sont venus
travailler également sur une
compatibilité avec les réseaux sociaux
ce qui fait que sur les applications
natives des réseaux sociaux Facebook
snapchat Instagram et TikTok et bien
vous aurez une fonctionnalité HDR pour
avoir un contenu totalement optimisé
comme si vous veniez shooter directement
avec l'application de votre smartphone
allez je donne les tarifs de ces
smartphones vous allez avoir bien
évidemment plusieurs versions entre les
différents smartphones on va commencer
par le S24 le S24 vous avez en 128 Go de
stockage il est à 899 € et si vous
voulez doubler en 256 ça vous coûtera
960 9 € si vous passez sur le Galaxy S24
plus 256 on est à 1169 € et la version
512 elle est à 1289 € et puis le ultra
le plus beau le plus haut version 256 on
est à 1469 € la version 512 elle sera
1589 € et puis la version 1 forcément la
plus chère 1829 € alors vous avez des
précommandes à partir du lancement donc
d'aujourd'hui jusqu'au 30 janvier et
bien Samsung va venir doubler votre
stockage ce qui fait que si vous voulez
un Samsung Galaxy S24 et bien vous aurez
le 256 au prix du 128 c'est la même
chose he si par exemple vous voulez un
512 et bien vous aurez le 1 TER au prix
du 512 c'est vachement cool en plus de
ça vous avez des bonus reprise pour les
Galaxy S24 et S24 plus 50 € de bonus
reprise tandis que pour le S24 ultra et
bien vous avez 100 € de bonus reprise
tout en sachant que ces produits seront
disponibles à la vente à partir du 31
janvier vous pouvez par contre dès à
présent les commander pour profiter bien
évidemment des meilleures conditions
doubl stockage et bonus reprise ça c'est
super intéressant il font très jolies
promesses il y a lia qui est là vraiment
intégré dans un smartphone je trouve ça
juste extraordinaire ça rend plein de
bons services d'ailleurs dites-moi vous
ce que vous en pensez puis si vous
n'avez pas encore vu les dernières
astuces pour venir bien utiliser votre
smartphone de Samsung la vidéo est là
allez jeter un œil vous m'en direz des
nouvell